Congress will have a lot to deal with
when lawmakers return from their summer
recess gun control at the top of the
Democrats agenda there's also obviously
immigration reform and everyone is
keeping an eye on Hong Kong North Korea
and Iran tonight we have a lot to talk
about with House Minority Leader Kevin
McCarthy of California he is on a trip
to Israel mr. leader thanks for being
here thanks for having me I appreciate
it first let's start on your trip what
you're taking from it and what you're
doing there well I brought 31 of the
Republican members over and we're
walking through Israel our greatest ally
in the Middle East the only country in
the Middle East that is a democracy who
met with the Prime Minister Bibi
Netanyahu we met the prime minister of
the Palestinian Authority we're up at
the border of Lebanon today looking at
Hezbollah's tunnels that they have
recently discovered coming across over
into Israel it gives you a very clear
understanding of the challenges for a
peace process here but it's a way that a
lot of the new freshmen who can see it
on the ground and we actually made it
bipartisan Steny Hoyer and I made sure
that Democrats and Republicans came
together for a number of days here in
Israel to look at the challenges
together and understand how do we
maintain this bond and even grow it to a
future gen you say this is my partisan
yet on this trip you've also expressed
your concerns about the squad the
freshmen Democrats who you say are
taking the Democratic Party away from
Israel explain that well if you look at
it they did not come on the trip with
their colleagues secondly if you look at
the anti-semitism that has been growing
around the world we haven't seen
something like this since the 1930s and
the actions that they have taken in
Congress itself whereas the Senate
passed s1 it's the anti BDS it's the
stopping of the boycott divest sure and
sanctions against Israel
well that bill passed the Senate
overwhelmingly Chuck Schumer not only
voted for it he co-sponsored it but when
it came to the house they couldn't pass
the bill they moved a resolution and
much of that was to do about this new
movement of this new socialist Democrat
and look look at what Bernie Sanders
look at Gamla Harris wouldn't even go to
the APEC meeting this year inside
Washington unheard-of in the process so
it's been going forward there's a number
of Democrats that still stand with
Israel but this new social socialist
Democrat group has a much different
belief you know Axios is reporting that
the president told American advisors
including senior administration
officials that Omar congresswoman Omar
and Talib should be barred from going to
Israel the administration's not
commenting Israel is not barring them
but any thought on that do you think the
president had those beliefs I never
heard the president say that to me
but the one thing that should have
happened they should have come with
their colleagues they should have come
together where they can have a meeting
with Israel with the Palestinian
Authority with those who were running
against Bibi at the same time you would
get every view that you wanted to see as
long as you come with an open mind open
eyes and open ears I think you have a
responsibility to come here to have an
understanding all right now let's talk
about the other issues of the day that
are pressing the House Speaker is
calling for action on gun control
legislation tickle ISM we must pass Gun
Violence Prevention legislation every
day we lose lives and now
public sentiment must weigh in to save
lives to pass our bill and to look at
high-capacity magazines that should be a
lemon
that bill did pass the house eight
Republicans voted for it you voted no on
this background check bill that included
other things it's now sitting in the
Senate what do you think the Senate
should do well I think the Senate should
actually pass a bill that actually works
and you got to understand what has this
last Congress done when we saw a
shooting like in parkland where that
individual and we never want to say his
name
the FBI was warned not once but twice
months ahead of time and no action was
taken or we saw that shooting in Texas
at a church what happened there was the
National instant criminal background
check failed it was it was our own
military that no longer gave the
information forward so we changed that
we did a we did a fix Nick's in that
process and when you look at the bump
stock that came through during the Obama
administration the Trump administration
took that back we would actually like to
see something that works in this process
and we're willing to work with anybody
we want to make sure we protect our due
process but we also want to make sure we
protect the Americans across for who
should have this all right well the
president as well he wants to see me
natural background checks on Tuesday he
said he thinks that Mitch McConnell
wants something to happen you voted
against that bill in the house do you
think something will happen on this edge
that doesn't because that bill does not
give you meaningful background checks
you could write a bill that actually
does that and I'm more than willing to
sit down with anyone and work on that
and I've talked reached out to Mitch's
well McConnell to find a way that we can
work on that I've spoken to the
president numerous times we want a
process that works we also want a
process that we have bills on the we
have laws today that aren't enforced the
number of people who try to buy a weapon
who are not legally have the right to do
it less than 8% of those are even
prosecuted today I want to go through a
couple of issues very quickly one is
your concern about what's happening in
Hong Kong and what potentially the US
could or could not do about it well I
think first of all America should stand
with those who believe in freedom it's a
fundamental part of our country America
is more than a country we are an idea an
idea of self-governance remember this is
the 30 year anniversary of Tiananmen
Square that was a defining moment we
watched those tanks roll in to the
millions of
who stood up and built a statue like the
Statue of Liberty just for the idea of
freedom of speech then what's happening
in China today every single person in
China gets a social score they're denied
whether they could fly on a plane if
they don't speak the way the government
wants them to inside Hong Kong with
those who are standing for freedom I
want them to know that America stands
with you the same as we stand with with
the shipyard workers in Poland in the
80s so the same reason that we stand
with those in Vince availa they crave
freedom as well all right quickly the
president is appearing to back off plans
to commute the sentence former Illinois
governor Rod Blagojevich is that from a
push from House Republicans I'm not sure
exactly where and I know the president
never said he was he was actually
analyzing it I don't think the president
should release the former governor you
know I think it's four out of five of
the last governors of Illinois have been
in jail and they've been in jail because
they stood before and they had a jury of
their peers make a decision I think they
should serve their time and I think
that's correct if the president makes
that decision to make them make him
continue to serve his time the southern
border issue Democrats expressing
concern about eminent domain saying were
troubled by the lack of transparency
particularly concerned that given land
owners whose property was seized during
Prior boarder barrier construction
efforts have told Congress they did not
receive just compensation for their land
they'd like to know what's happening
this time with the efforts to build a
border wall they can see all they want
but the Democrats aren't concerned about
that they're more concerned about having
open borders I've never understood a
situation where you see a crisis even
the New York Times has written an
editorial not once but twice
about the crisis along our southern
border but has there been any hearings
in judiciary about this has there been
any action and now that the Democrats
are concerned about eminent domain our
private property I think that's far far
from it because I haven't seen them care
about that before all they are more
concerned about is having an open border
system which is not we want to have a
legal immigration system and we want one
that actually works last thing your
colleague representative Steve King was
talking to a conservative Club Wednesday
and he said that humanity might not
exist at all if
for rape and incest throughout human
history if you pulled out a product of
rape or incest would there be any
population of the world left if we did
that you have any problem with that
construction have a great deal of
problems with that this isn't the first
time I've had concerns with what Steve
King has said earlier in this Congress
there are things that Steve King said
that I do not believe the party of
Lincoln would stand for and as it as a
United Conference we actually remove
Steve King from his committees inside
Congress and I think this just continues
to show why that action was taken mr.
leader we appreciate your time safe
travels on your trip